y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en donde
hacemos un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
de kobe 19 en nuestro continente a
continuación algunos de los temas que
vamos a tratar en el programa de hoy
hablaremos de uruguay el país que dio ya
por finalizada la emergencia sanitaria
que fue declarada el 13 de marzo de 2020
cuando fueron detectados los primeros
casos de kobe 19 vamos a conocer en
detalle qué implica el fin de las
restricciones y cómo los uruguayos
seguirán protegiendo sed el coronavirus
también como paliarán los efectos de la
pandemia de jovi 19 en términos
económicos de uruguay vamos a pasar
hasta brasil el país en donde los casos
de dengue han aumentado un 35 por ciento
no solamente preocupa el aumento de los
casos en medio de la pandemia de kobe 19
también preocupa la escasez de
inmunizantes para hacer frente a esta
nueva problemática de salud en minutos
tendremos detalles desde la ciudad de
río de janeiro y en nuestra habitual
consulta con el doctor pérez nuestro
asesor científico hablaremos del nuevo
sub linaje que está derivada de la
variante omicron y de los efectos que ha
dejado también en millones de personas
en kobe 19 estamos hablando del llamado
hobbit largo y en particular de los
problemas oculares que ha causado
comenzamos
y lo hacemos entonces con cifras vamos a
actualizar las cifras y algunos datos
importantes veamos cómo termina la
semana algunos de los países andinos en
cuanto al avance de la pandemia siguen
registrándose datos y más cifras y
contagios por supuesto estos datos
corresponden entonces a reportes
oficiales de las autoridades locales de
contagios y fallecidos reportados en los
últimos 28 días comienzo en colombia en
donde en estos últimos 28 días ya fueron
contabilizados un poco más de 12.400
casos y 473 personas han fallecido un
poco más de esta cifra en venezuela en
los últimos 28 días fueron registrados
más de 3400 casos y más de 36 personas
fallecieron en ecuador' las cifras ya
superan los 19 mil 600 casos y en 28
días 145 personas fallecieron pero
reportó más de 19 mil 100 casos y los
fallecidos en estos últimos 28 días son
como ustedes lo ven en la cifra un poco
más de mil 66 fallecidos allí en perú
por su parte bolivia reportó más de
6.300 casos y 4 123 personas perdieron
la vida en ese país andino
para profundizar en todo lo que ha
ocurrido a lo largo de esta semana las
novedades que hay y avances que tenemos
en cuanto a datos sobre la pandemia de
kobe 19 está con nosotros el doctor
carlos eduardo pérez él es el médico
infectólogo también asesor científico de
france 24 doctor como siempre un gusto
tenerlo en el programa gracias por estar
con nosotros abre entonces esta agenda
de consulta y comienzo preguntándole por
esa variante o sub linaje sí que es una
combinación de varias sub variantes de
omicron tenemos algunos datos básicos
doctor como para tenerlo como punto de
partida es una recombinación del virus
también es de una transmisión un 10 por
ciento mayor que la de la variante o su
linaje ve a punto 2 es el sub linaje de
o micro más común en este momento y
todavía está bajo investigación de los
expertos pero que se sabía al respecto
doctor
alguna cosa muy importante santiago es
que estos sub linajes como otras
variantes van a seguir apareciendo
recordemos que mientras hayan personas
susceptibles mientras haya personas no
inmunizadas o que pierdan inmunidad el
virus va a circular y entre más allá de
lo circulante más probabilidades que
aparezca lo que sabemos actualmente es
que se incrementa la transmisión con
esta sub variante sin embargo no está
documentado que sea más virulenta ni
tampoco que nos sirvan las vacunas hasta
ahora la evidencia que tenemos es que
para las variantes que han aparecido las
vacunas siempre funciona es de esperar
que en esta sub variante que no hay
mayores modificaciones genéticas siga
siendo activa en la vacuna el gran
problema es en las personas no
inmunizadas o que han perdido la
inmunidad que no se han hecho los
refuerzos donde probablemente este este
es un linaje vaya a ser predominante de
las próximas semanas
el doctor rápidamente un término
recombinación del virus que significa
esto exactamente los virus tienen la
propiedad de hacer y recombinación
quiere decir que comparten algún
material genético entonces eso lo vemos
mucho en influenza donde el virus que
está circulando en un animal por ejemplo
en una vez se recombina con el de los
seres humanos aquí lo que sucede es que
estas variantes cambian intercambian
algunas de sus sustancias que son de
importancia inmunológica y por eso se
recombinan es decir combinan varias
estrategias para ver siguiente infectar
esa recombinación de lo que generan las
variantes hablemos del sub linaje ve a
punto 2 que también es una derivada de
omicron se están presentando cada vez
más datos de casos en diferentes países
de américa latina estamos ante un
posible repunte en las próximas semanas
lo que hemos visto con esta variante
grados que es lo que también sucede en
europa es en población no inmunizada y
también en personas que han recibido la
inmunización pero han pasado más de seis
meses y no enrique no han recibido el
refuerzo es importante que estas
variantes solamente son se predecir a
una nueva ola que de acuerdo a los
niveles de inmunización que tengamos en
el en el organismo para estas unidades
de a dos las dosis más el refuerzo son
bastante efectivos pero dosis sin
refuerzo no parecen ser efectivas de
aquel llamado sigas a hacer que se llame
vacunación completa la vacunación que
tiene al menos tres dosis doctor países
por como por ejemplo uruguay están
levantando las restricciones las
personas que ya están vacunadas tienen
los refuerzos como pueden seguir
cuidándose y previniendo el contagio de
kobe 19 cuando ya no hay que lavarse las
manos frecuentemente cuando ya no hay
que guardar el distanciamiento social y
no hay que usar tapabocas
el tapabocas es una de las partes que lo
pueden limitar y va a ser muy importante
en personas que tengan síntomas los
otros que si alguna persona tiene
síntomas respiratorios haga un
aislamiento no vaya a ser mercado a ir a
un espectáculo deportivo etcétera la
higiene de manos va a seguir y es
importante no solamente para esta
enfermedad respiratoria sino para la
salud pública lo que debemos fortalecer
son esas medidas de higiene aprenderse a
lavar las manos usar frecuentemente
desinfectantes en las manos es una
estrategia que servirá para ésta y para
otras infecciones respiratorias esas son
las medidas que tenemos que mantener
tres importantes si tiene síntomas
respiratorios a él le se usan tapabocas
si tiene síntomas respiratorios y
siempre nada de mono las manos y
mantengamos la higiene como estructura y
parte fundamental para controlar este y
otros virus respiratorios ahí tienen
ustedes tres recomendaciones importantes
doctor el cob y largo que son los
problemas que dejan las secuelas que
dejan a las personas que han padecido
kobe 19 vamos a enfocarnos en el
programa de hoy
en los problemas oculares personas que
quedan con ardor en los ojos
enrojecimiento de los ojos que
constantemente están expulsando lágrimas
como consecuencia después de haber
padecido kobe 19 que hacer en estos
casos cada semana vamos a estar hablando
de algún síntoma de kobe largo a partir
del día de hoy queremos que nos cuenten
a través de las redes sociales si a
ustedes les ha pasado algo como
consecuencia del cob y todavía lo están
padeciendo
repito el kobe largo que son síntomas
que persisten y se siguen repitiendo en
los pacientes
de esta enfermedad y sobre todo el caso
de largo estamos aprendiendo ya hemos
visto por ejemplo en programas
anteriores el compromiso este articular
los compromisos pulmonares revisamos las
complicaciones cardíacas y unas muy
importantes que son las alteraciones en
la memoria y neurológicas de ccoo de
largo sobre el sistema visual tenemos
dos cosas importantes hay una afectación
que puede ser por la afectación viral
directa que es en la parte aguda pero se
ha visto que en los pacientes con cover
prolongado pueden haber fenómenos de
inflamación ocular se llaman uveítis o
unas con conjuntivitis que parece que no
responden al tratamiento sin embargo no
se ha documentado que hayan secuelas o
que sea una algo muy frecuente pero sí
se recomienda si hay alteraciones
visuales consultar al oftalmólogo para
elegir el que dirigir el tratamiento de
este color largo estamos aprendiendo
realmente cada día aprendemos más y el
compromiso ocular si lo vemos en el
poder prolongado y será materia de
estudio en las próximos meses para ver
cómo enfrentamos o prevenimos este
problema doctor pérez muchísimas gracias
por esta consulta haber aclarado como
siempre nuestras preguntas y dudas en
torno a estos diferentes temas muchas
gracias bueno a continuación les
presento el porcentaje de población que
ha recibido dosis de refuerzo o cuarta
dosis dependiendo de los casos en alguna
serie de países al azar en nuestro
continente comencemos por ejemplo en el
norte en el extremo norte en canadá allí
el 48 26 por ciento de la población ya
tiene la dosis de refuerzo en estados
unidos ya la alcanzó allí la cifra del
29 65 por ciento de la población con
refuerzo en perú llegan al 39 67 por
ciento argentina el 42 75 por ciento y
finalizamos en brasil en donde el
48,26 por ciento de la población ya
recibió la dosis de refuerzo que en
algunos casos es tercera o cuarta dosis
y ya lo decíamos esta semana uruguay se
convirtió en uno de los primeros países
de américa latina en anunciar el fin de
la emergencia sanitaria que fue
declarada el pasado 13 de marzo del año
2020 la decisión fue tomada debido a esa
buena situación que está presentando
uruguay en términos sanitarios
sanitarios y eso terminó con una
temporada de verano en la que recibieron
muchísimos visitantes y los casos de
contagio de kobe 19 estuvieron
relativamente controlados los detalles
los tiene que harina de almas desde la
ciudad de punta del este en el
departamento de maldonado allí en la
costa uruguaya karina gracias por
acompañarnos en el programa y bueno qué
implica entonces esta medida para
uruguay para la economía para la
sociedad el alcance de esta de este
anuncio hecho por las autoridades
uruguayas
efectivamente santiago a poco más de dos
años de que el gobierno uruguayo
decretar la emergencia sanitaria
este decidió darla por concluida luego
de informes del ministerio de salud
pública que indicará el número de casos
diarios de contagios de kobe 19 han
disminuido dramáticamente también el
alto porcentaje de la población que ya
está vacunada contra la enfermedad y el
número de personas inmunizadas luego de
haber contraído el cob y 19 hasta el
momento en uruguay se registraron más de
890.000 casos de los cuales 77 mil 171
resultaron de personas fallecidas y
actualmente se encuentran unas cinco mil
personas cursando la enfermedad el
ministro de salud pública daniel salinas
indicó
la situación epidemiológica del país
permite poder tomar medidas para
acercarse a una
normalidad en las actividades de la
población este fue parte del análisis
que realizó el ministro salinas es un
momento epidemiológico y muy favorable
para el país esto está basado en
criterios
objetivos muy particularmente lo que es
la incidencia de casos nuevos semanales
lo que es
y la repercusión a nivel sanitario tanto
a nivel de cuidar camas de cuidados
moderados como camas de cti y lo mismo
lo que tiene que ver con la gravedad de
la afección en cuanto a la cantidad de
fallecidos por 100.000 habitantes
karina eso en cuanto al término
sanitario y la emergencia sanitaria y en
uruguay pero que hay entonces de la
economía que van a hacer para recuperar
la economía uruguaya también afectada
efectivamente por la pandemia a nivel
social entonces esto que implica ya el
país regresa entonces en cierta forma a
la normalidad a las escuelas que están
próximas a iniciar también el nuevo año
académico
santiago lo que ha generado mayor
impacto y también gran incertidumbre en
la población se refiere al uso del
tapabocas ya que las autoridades ahora
plantean que es una recomendación pero
no una obligación incluso las
autoridades sanitarias vieron que es
recomendable en el transporte público
pero no una obligación por su parte
mientras muchos celebraban una vuelta a
la normalidad varias empresas
consultaban a sus asesores legales sobre
cómo actuar muchos abogados indicaron
que las empresas privadas pueden tomar
una decisión y es legal así como también
lo es
limitar el derecho a acceso a un
servicio oa una propiedad como puede ser
un local comercial a personas por
ejemplo que deseen ingresar con una
mascota
la mayoría de los abogados indican que
bueno las empresas pueden seguir
decidiendo si exigen o no el uso del
tapabocas en víspera a las celebraciones
de semana santa la iglesia católica
aconsejó a sus sacerdotes y fieles a
usarlos durante la misas que se van a
estar realizando esta semana y se
esperan sean muy concurridas en cuanto a
la educación las autoridades decidieron
que no va a haber cuarentenas en los
centros educativos incluso cuando haya
más de dos casos por grupo escolar y
tampoco se le exige más a los docentes
el uso del
tapabocas las autoridades sanitarias
recordaron que se debe seguir tomando
medidas y apelaron una vez más a la
responsabilidad ciudadana sobre todas
las personas de alto riesgo de contraer
el hobbie 19 en cuanto a los turistas y
el ingreso al país el gobierno uruguayo
únicamente exige un test de kobe 19 a
quienes ingresan al país sin tener
vacunación previa karina punto
importante el instituto nacional de
estadística de uruguay presentó los
datos del 2021 sobre la pobreza y la
desigualdad en la república oriental
cifras que han variado mucho a lo largo
de estos meses debido precisamente a la
emergencia sanitaria de la pandemia
santiago el informe del instituto
nacional de estadística se dio a conocer
el 30 de marzo pero en las últimas horas
generó gran polémica y es que mientras
el gobierno del presidente luis lacalle
pou ve con optimismo que en el último
año la pobreza bajó del 11,6 al 10,6 y
lo refiere a las medidas implementadas
por el gobierno la oposición acusa al
presidente propiamente dicho ya la
ministra de economía de falsear la
información
especialmente durante la última campaña
electoral con el referéndum de la ley de
urgente consideración que permitió que
la
estrategia del presidente
continuará en cuanto a las leyes y a las
medidas económicas entre otros temas
señala
y los datos refieren a una disminución
entre el 2021 en relación al 2020 pero
no previo a la pandemia cuando el índice
de pobreza se encontraba en el 8.8 por
ciento y denuncian que el gobierno faltó
a la verdad durante la campaña electoral
karina muchas gracias por este reporte
desde la bella ciudad de punta del este-
allí en la riviera uruguaya vamos a
cambiar de tema la organización
panamericana de la salud advirtió que la
sub variante ve a punto 2 derivada de la
variante omicron está a punto de
provocar una nueva ola de contagios en
el continente americano lo conversamos
ahora con el doctor pérez por lo menos
así lo refleja la situación que está
viviendo el continente europeo y china
que es parte del espejo que tenemos aquí
en américa veamos por qué la sub
variante ve a dos de omicron y ha sido
detectada en 87 por ciento de las
secuencias reportadas en américa del sur
según la organización panamericana de la
salud quien agregó que esta situación se
esperaba luego de ver un repunte en
europa y en el este de asia bea 2 ya es
dominante en eeuu mientras que en canadá
actualmente las hospitalizaciones
aumentaron un 10% y los casos un tercio
en comparación con la semana del 20 al
26 de marzo en
todo el caribe 15 países y territorios
también experimentaron un aumento en las
nuevas infecciones
informes de muertes también aumentaron
en toda la región
la hoy bs informó que la vacunación ha
sido un aspecto decisivo en el avance de
esta su variante alertó que pese a las
altas tasas en la región más de 240
millones de personas no han recibido ni
una sola dosis la organización también
responsabiliza el levantamiento
prematuro de los protocolos contra el
kobe 19
a medida que se relajaron las
restricciones de viaje el número de
casos aumentó en lugares que dependen
del turismo especialmente en partes de
américa del norte y el caribe
para luchar contra la aparición de
nuevas variantes la opep se urgió a las
autoridades de los países a mantener
fácil acceso a las pruebas de detección
a pesar del avance de la variante vea
dos los casos semanales de kobe 19 en la
región de las américas han disminuido
menos en américa del norte
más temas hay preocupación por parte de
las autoridades sanitarias en brasil por
un aumento de hasta un 35% en los casos
de contagio de dengue y temen que la
situación escale y ahora deban hacer
frente a una epidemia y también a una
pandemia al mismo tiempo los detalles
los tiene valeria sacones desde la
ciudad de río de janeiro valeria binding
del programa y bueno ya lo decía yo 35
por ciento en el aumento de los casos
también es preocupante que hay escasez
en brásil de los medicamentos para poder
hacer frente al dengue cuál es la
situación
si no hay que olvidar que brasil es un
país tropical en los primeros dos meses
de este año ha habido un aumento de los
casos de dengue del 35,4 por ciento con
30 muertos y más de 128.000 casos
detectados el problema que a día de hoy
no hay una vacuna desarrollada en tiempo
récord como la vacuna que se ha que ha
aparecido para contrarrestar el avance
del comité 19 hay una única vacuna
desarrollada por el laboratorio francés
sanofi pasteur sin embargo no es
distribuida gratuitamente por el sistema
público de salud porque es una vacuna
considerada problemática porque está
recomendada solamente para las personas
que ya hayan tenido contacto con el
virus hay estudios que demuestran que
las personas que nunca tuvieron contacto
con el virus pueden desarrollar una vez
vacunadas una versión mucho más
peligrosa que puede derivar en
hospitalización entonces la vacuna
existente además de ser cara supone un
estrés para el sistema público porque
habría que hacer tests en todas las
personas que la vayan a recibir
qué hace justo un año la agencia
nacional del medicamento recibió otra
vacuna la está analizando todavía no se
ha pronunciado y finalmente el
laboratorio brasileño instituto butantán
lleva 10 años investigando su propia
vacuna la realidad es que el día de hoy
el dengue todavía no tiene una solución
y como vemos está avanzando en medio de
una pandemia del coronavirus que todavía
no se acaba
valeria dejemos de lado el tema del
dengue pasemos ahora el tema del cobi
19brasilia superó los 30 millones de
casos de contagio de kobe y sigue siendo
todo un tema allí para la salud pública
en brasil cuál es la situación
si los datos de la organización mundial
de la salud muestran que brasil es el
tercer país del mundo con más casos sólo
después de eeuu y de la india ya se
contabilizan más de 660 mil muertos para
que recordar que brasil ha demostrado
ser un campeón en la vacunación a día de
hoy el 75 por ciento de su inmensa
población de 212 millones de personas ya
está totalmente vacunado estamos
hablando de 161 millones de personas eso
sí es muy pronto para cantar victoria
porque esta semana ha sido detectada en
sanpaolo un caso de una sub variante de
lado micrófono lado micrófono x que
supuestamente es mucho más contagiosa el
informe médico habla de una sub variante
que habría llegado desde suráfrica y que
fue detectada en un varón de 39 años eso
despierta el fantasma de una nueva ola
de contagios
valeria como usted nos dice con 160
millones de personas vacunadas ya
también redujeron algunas de las
restricciones para los viajeros de qué
tipo de restricciones estamos hablando y
cuáles son los cambios
con la mejora de los datos sobre la
pandemia en todo el mundo brasil ha
levantado algunas restricciones los
viajeros que lleguen a brasil y que
hayan recibido al menos dos dosis de
vacuna en su país ya no precisan a
presentar un certificado de una prueba
contra el comité solo necesitan el
certificado de vacunación de su propio
país de procedencia ya sea en papel o un
certificado electrónico ahora bien las
personas que hayan recibido menos de dos
dosis de vacunas es así tienen que
presentar una prueba de pcr o de
antígeno para demostrar que no están
contagiadas esto si ya no es obligatorio
observar una cuarentena en solo
brasileño
valeria muy obligado muchas gracias por
este reporte pasemos ahora a datos del
cierre de esta semana relacionados con
la vacunación les presento a
continuación el porcentaje de la
población
inoculada con la dosis del protocolo
inicial de vacunación que era de una o
dos dosis dependiendo de la vacuna que
la persona recibiera en esta oportunidad
veremos datos de centroamérica y vamos a
comenzar entonces en guatemala allí
solamente el 32 88 por ciento de la
población tiene las dosis completas del
protocolo inicial en belice la cifra
llega al 51 76 por ciento pasamos al
salvador la cifra supera el 65 57 por
ciento para el cierre de esta semana
honduras allí alcanza el 45 54 por
ciento nicaragua alcanza el 65 53 por
ciento de la población con el protocolo
completo aunque las cifras no son muy
recientes
costa rica que es el líder de la región
termina esta semana con el 78% de la
población vacunada con la dosis completa
al protocolo inicial y panamá supera el
69 por ciento de la población
y ya lo hemos dicho varias veces aquí en
el programa chile es uno de los países
que fue el líder de la vacunación a
nivel mundial sus rígidas medidas de
prevención también le permitieron hacer
frente a la pandemia de kobe 19 eso sí
dejando un alto costo para la economía
chilena esta gestión del gobierno
anterior porque hubo un cambio de
gobierno recientemente recibió el premio
franz edelman awards 2022 por la
implementación de un sistema integrado
de búsqueda de casos y de cruce de datos
que le permitió hacer un seguimiento a
los casos de kobe 19 vamos a conocer
entonces más detalles sobre este premio
y la situación allí en chile con nuestra
corresponsal permanente en santiago
patricia de una patricia que dicen las
autoridades de este premio que
recibieron y pues la implementación de
este sistema integrado de búsqueda
activa de datos que tal parece les
funciona muy bien hay en chile
santi pues una plataforma para
monitorear la movilidad de la población
durante las cuarentenas un sistema para
detectar casos asintomáticos en lugares
críticos un programa para evaluar la
reacción de los anticuerpos ante las
distintas vacunas y una metodología que
asigna distintos tipos de camas en una
red de hospitales públicos son algunos
de los innovadores sistemas por el que
el instituto de sistemas complejos de la
universidad de chile- ha recibido este
prestigioso premio en el que
participaban también importantes
empresas internacionales como general
motors o alibaba entre otros el primer
lo recibe de esta forma la universidad
de chile junto el ministerio de salud y
de ciencias son las antiguas autoridades
del antiguo gobierno la ex subsecretaria
de salud paula daza una figura muy
conocida y querida por los chilenos por
su gestión de la pandemia y también el
ex ministro de ciencias descubre los que
recogen este premio que supone un
reconocimiento más y también valora los
200 millones que supusieron en ahorro
las 65 mil infecciones que se evitaron y
las 2800 muertes que también dejaron de
producirse debido a la alimentación de
este innovador sistema que recibe este
prestigioso reconocimiento un premio más
a la exitosa gestión de la pandemia y
también el plan de vacunación que ha
caracterizado a chile en estos últimos
años la prensa muy interesante pero
también interesante saber con este
cambio de gobierno entonces la gestión
los protocolos y el manejo de la
pandemia cambio o van a seguir
utilizando este modelo exitoso
pues llevamos casi un mes de la
instalación del nuevo gobierno y fue el
pasado lunes en el que no en las nuevas
autoridades sanitarias encabezadas por
la ministra de salud maría de goya ya
anunciaron una remodelación del plan
paso a paso elaborado por el anterior
gobierno de sebastián piñera
ahora asistirán tres etapas una etapa de
baja contagiosidad de la pandemia una
fase de media y una fase alta en la que
se medirán factores como la ocupación de
las unidades de cuidados intensivos el
registro de las personas con
enfermedades respiratorias y en función
de eso se tomarán una serie de medidas
así en la fase de bajo riesgo digamos no
existirán las mascarillas ni en lugares
abiertos ni en lugares cerrados lo que
sí sabemos es que a partir del próximo
14 de abril los chilenos por primera vez
desde hace bastantes meses desde casi el
comienzo de la pandemia desde que se
instalará la mascarilla los espacios
públicos no tendrán por qué llevar
mascarilla cuando estén al aire libre y
puedan mantener un metro de distancia
con otras personas será la primera vez
en muchos meses algo que se justifica
según la nueva ministra de salud ya está
porque los efectos mentales de la
pandemia también se sienten en la
población hay un agotamiento y es
importante que dar este tipo de señales
en una población en el que más del 90
por ciento ha recibido vacunas es esa la
justificación para eliminar las
mascarillas se relajan las medidas en
chile en un momento en el que la
pandemia no se sitúa en la primera línea
de preocupaciones ni de la población ni
del gobierno claro el agotamiento es de
todos patricia hablemos ahora de la
situación actual en cuanto a los casos
al número de fallecidos y personas
contagiadas y vacunadas
3800 casos registrados en las últimas 24
horas una positividad de 5 71 por ciento
en todo el país y un 6 en la región
metropolitana chile vive un momento
bastante calmo en cuanto a las cifras de
la pandemia que han bajado mucho
respecto a la de las últimas semanas en
total han sido más de tres millones y
medio de chilenos los que se han
contagiado de kobe desde el inicio de la
pandemia en casi 57.000 fallecidos más
de 13 millones de dosis de refuerzo ya
se han aplicado a una población en la
que casi el 94% de la población objetiva
de 15,2 millones de chilenos frente a
los 19 que existen ya han recibido a un
sistema de vacunación completo vivimos
un momento por el tanto en el que se
comienzan a relajar las medidas se van a
eliminar las mascarillas y también se
habla de la reapertura de las fronteras
terrestres y también de relajar un poco
más las medidas de entrada de turistas
en el aeropuerto algo que podríamos ver
en las próximas semanas
patricia gracias por este reporte desde
la ciudad de santiago la capital de
chile cambiamos de tema un nuevo revés
para el gobierno del presidente joe
biden se vio en el congreso de estados
unido los republicanos decidieron frenar
un paquete de recursos por 10.000
millones de dólares destinados a hacer
frente a la pandemia de kobe y 19 en un
país en donde ya comenzaron a presentar
varios casos del sub linaje ve a punto 2
de la variante omicron
bloqueados los fondos para luchar contra
el cobre y 19 los republicanos del
congreso de eeuu no aprobaron un paquete
por 10 mil millones de dólares que
serían invertidos en tratamientos
pruebas y vacunas a pesar de las
advertencias de la casa blanca que la
pandemia de kobe 19 no ha terminado el
virus no está esperando a que los
republicanos en el congreso se pongan
las pilas sabemos que él ve a dos está
aquí el gobierno ha terminado y tenemos
la obligación de proteger a nuestro país
al pueblo estadounidense y asegurarnos
de que estamos tomando medidas y nos
estamos preparando según los centros
para el control de enfermedades el sub
linaje ba2 ya representa más de la mitad
de los nuevos casos detectados en eeuu
en los estados de nueva york y new
jersey ya representa más del 70 por
ciento de los casos el país es el más
golpeado por la pandemia en el mundo son
más de 80 millones 200 mil contagios y
casi un millón de muertes el opositor
partido republicano encabeza de mitch
mcconnell dijo que iban a proponer
varias enmiendas al paquete de 2019
el paquete de cómic ha sido negociado a
un nivel de 10.000 millones de dólares
requeriría creó varias enmiendas para
poder pasar en el congreso
así que si el líder de la mayoría
intenta avanzar tendremos que debatir
sobre un proceso de enmiendas razonables
tras el fracaso de este acuerdo se
desconoce el futuro del plan para
enfrentar el virus los legisladores
estadounidenses entrarán en un receso de
dos semanas por lo que se espera que
retome el tema hacia finales de mes este
es el segundo intento del gobierno de
bailén para conseguir los recursos que
necesita su administración en marzo un
grupo de demócratas de la cámara de
representantes- frenó la iniciativa por
estar ligada a las ayudas de ucrania
no salimos por unos minutos del
continente americano nos vamos hasta
china porque allí el aumento de casos
llevó a que el gobierno de la ciudad de
shanghai anunciara un nuevo paquete de
medidas con muchas restricciones muy
estrictas incluso algunas de ellas
provocaron descontento por parte de los
ciudadanos veamos
llevados en cunas son separados de sus
padres
estas imágenes de niños pequeños en
pabellones de aislamiento han despertado
la indignación pública en las redes
sociales chinas mientras shanghai
intenta tomar medidas contra un nuevo
brote de scooby 19 la reacción ha
llevado a las autoridades a flexibilizar
las normas para hacer excepciones para
los niños que necesitan cuidados
especiales con la condición de que los
padres lleven máscaras y coman a una
hora diferente a la de sus hijos
para los niños con necesidades
especiales estamos aceptando solicitudes
de sus padres que con pleno conocimiento
de los posibles riesgos para la salud
puedan acompañar a sus hijos tras firmar
una carta de compromiso cada
una
shanghai ha creado centros de
aislamiento para decenas de miles de
personas en toda la ciudad incluyendo la
transformación de un enorme centro de
convenciones en un pabellón para
enfermos de kobe mediante el montaje de
unidades improvisadas la ciudad más
poblada del país logró contener el brote
hasta marzo con pruebas masivas y
estrictas restricciones de movimiento
pero ha cedido ante el número récord de
casos de la variante o micro 25 millones
de habitantes de shanghai
la orden de quedarse en casa desde la
semana pasada con la mayoría de los
trabajadores esenciales con permiso
especial para estar en las calles las
autoridades aún no han anunciado cuándo
saldrá la ciudad del bloqueo sumando un
nuevo golpe a la economía de china y
generando una creciente frustración
pública mientras el país continúa con su
enfoque de tolerancia cero para el
commit 19 y terminamos nuestro programa
dando un vistazo a otras noticias
relacionadas con la pandemia que también
fueron destacadas a través de las redes
sociales o ms disminuyen casos y muertos
en el mundo por kobe 19 el mundo reporta
una segunda semana en cuanto a la caída
de casos y de fallecidos esto representa
un retroceso del 16% un 16% menos que la
semana pasada las cifras de crecen
vienen también acompañadas de
incertidumbre porque muchos países han
desistido de realizar pruebas de pcr de
manera general lo que significa que hay
muchos casos sin detectar se queda
considera situación favorable para
analizar la eliminación del uso del uso
del tapabocas estamos hablando de
guillermo sequera el director general de
vigilancia de la salud en parãs este
país allí están estudiando la
posibilidad de eliminar el uso del
tapabocas debido a que están en una
meseta de contagio y así concluyen
también la novena semana de disminución
de disminución de casos de contagio de
kobe 19
cuarta dosis de vacunas se aplicará a
mayores de 70 años este grupo
poblacional junto a pacientes
inmunodeprimidos recibirán la tercera
dosis o la debían haber recibido la
tercera dosis hace más de cinco meses
para poder recibir esta cuarta dosis o
dosis de refuerzo la inoculación
comenzará en lima la capital de perú
país del que estamos hablando
precisamente
y esto fue todo hoy en kobe 19 la semana
en américa nos vemos la próxima semana
con más noticias destacadas de nuestro
continente sigan cuidando se la pandemia
sigue existiendo sigue persistente el
coronavirus lávese las manos usen el
tapabocas y sigan viendo france24
[Música]